I want to think back to yesterday
afternoon and I introduced to you three
kinds of objects all related to each
other and that all conveniently as far
as I can twelve tell I think it's given
to I'll start with the letter S what
were the three kinds of objects stopping
top okay we begin with that set which is
just now you have to write together what
is a set it's just a collection of
objects right a bunch of things in a
pile okay and you've got some objects
various qualities if you take a set and
you add order to it you get up if
something is sequential
it has order to it ABCD is a different
sequence to dcba
so a set plus order equals a sequence
right and then if you do one more thing
if you take a sequence and you add up
all the terms what do we call that
surgeries we call them once we kick all
the trolls out of the class we call it a
series okay now let's add a little more
language on this right now because
sequences of the series because they
both have ah
both have border associated with them
right we therefore call both of these we
give them like a broader category name
we cover progressions because from one
term to another you can talk about going
forward or going backward there's this
direction here there's you can talk
about them progressively or regressive
where is it a set that doesn't make
sense we don't progress through a set
because there's no water implied in that
right so you do have a sequence or a
series both within my chord progression
now there's loads of different kinds of
progressions I showed you a couple
yesterday you had a look at some very
simple words but there are two types of
progression that this topic to focus on
you can do a lot of them what I call
low-hanging fruit
so the mathematics of these two kinds of
progressions and we're talking about are
quite accessible and built on bless you
they build on some things you re doing
and it also grown in some really
important directions good morning
okay so I'm going to tell you about
where in today's triple and by the way
you totally lucked out because you guys
doing the main stockroom the mist off is
afraid right beak right and so you've
got a lot of people around the edges on
the walls and then you've got a whole
bunch of like cubicles in the middle
everyone sitting at cubicles in the
middle myself included it doesn't have
electricity because there's something
wrong with the wiring or whatever in the
end just fine
but every in the middle not fine and so
I don't have access to my printer so you
guys lucked out I don't get a quiz today
getting lucky for week one the quiz
today as a result in these three lessons
we're going to cover both of these kinds
of progressions with regard to how they
work with sequences okay when you dig
into seriously there's a lot more to
explore so we will take time undo them
so the first kind of a time so we're
going to we're gonna fill in this table
as we go the first time issues is what
we call and Eric makes an admin
progression okay now let me just make a
quick note here this word the spelling
of this word is two things it's either
an adjective or it's a noun right well
it's an adjective it's arithmetic that's
how I'm using it right now right if it's
a noun it's
arithmetic which is like it's a thing
it's a it's a fuel of mathematics
arithmetic arithmetic everybody get it
right now because what I'm looking at
here are arithmetic progressions we
because it just rolls off the tongue we
call this a P I'm going to stop saying
arithmetic progressions because ain't
nobody got time to say that baby so much
so we're saying a piece from now on and
hopefully you in this context who know
I'm not talking about excessive periods
well I don't you about arithmetic
progressions now let's talk about a few
things to do with these eight peas right
now yesterday I stand that for any of
these you can define them in one of
three ways one of three ways do you
remember what the three ways to define a
sequence what the first time the
simplest one is not it's a pattern right
so in other words if you give me a set
of values I can tell you how that
sequence will keep going how will
progress now what makes and arithmetic
progressions and arithmetic progression
is that between each of the terms in the
sequence and you have a common
difference so for instance the odd
numbers 1 3 5 7 9 they're an AP right
because there's a common difference
between every term namely between your
numbers then we zoom right you add 2 you
get 4 1 2 3 you add 2 to get from 3 to 5
add 2 & 2 that's you the even numbers
are also an AP right but you can get a
whole bunch of ones I mean for instance
I think the one I started with if there
was one four seven all right this is an
AP that's the one that's a reason why I
started with it actually it's not the
odd numbers it's not the even numbers
it's not even the multiples of three the
multiples of three add one but it's an
AP do you see why it's an AP when you go
from one term to the next all you're
doing is adding this common difference
okay so let's try and speak in general
terms if what we do is we start with the
first term of our series and because
it's the first one we call it a as in
first
and if all doing is adding a value she
gets the next one and the next one in
April for the next one right if a is
just the first value to get to the next
one I'll start with that value but
they're not add another will add a
common difference and because the
difference we call it D okay now that
will be the first and second times how
am I gonna get to the third term if all
I'm doing is adding another common
difference very good a plus 2 D right so
for instance in this case here what do
we have
I had a first value of sorry a common
difference is I have the first value of
1 and I have a common difference of 3
and sure enough they're equals 1
there's a plus D and there's a plus 2 D
because 1 plus 6 right and don't know
thought I don't need to know anymore I
have the patent established okay but
that wasn't the only way to define a
sequence right always a nickel a after
pan you can use a formula right can you
tell me how to get directly to the nth
term in terms of n right now what's n in
this case right for this first term here
right
how many common differences do I have I
don't have any do I there's kind of like
a plus 0 D sort of hiding in there my I
just don't write it here I have one lot
of common difference and here I have two
right so the first term has none of them
the second term has one the third term
has two right - so to get the nth term
I'm always going to start with that
first term right but what do I add how
many lots of the difference do I need to
add to get to the end turn and it's not
yes it's gonna be n minus 1 because for
the third term on e - for the fourth
term only three always one last right so
n minus 1 lots of the common difference
that's how I get should be entered